JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
FROM DALLAS IS REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN JOHN RATCLIFF
CONTRIBUTOR, CHIEF POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT FOR "THE
WASHINGTON EXAMINER" AND
VICTORIA TOENSING A FORMER
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
IN THE REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION.
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET
THROUGH, GUYS.
LET'S START WITH YOU,
CONGRESSMAN.
BOY, THE DEMOCRATS WERE
COMING AT YOU GUYS WITH
EVERYTHING TODAY.
BASICALLY SAYING THIS IS A
BIG DUD.
THAT YOU'RE ENDANGERING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THEY ARE
STILL KEEPING UP WITH THE
AND SOURCES.
POURED ALL OVER THE AIRWAYS
TODAY?
SCHIFF ABOUT PROTECTING
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
THE IRONY OF THAT IS NOT
LOST ON A LOT OF FOLKS IN
WASHINGTON WHO ARE EQUIPSED
KEEPING SECRETS.
YOU KNOW, I UNDERSTAND WHY
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD BE UPSET
WITH WHAT THEY READ IN THAT
MEMO TODAY.
BUT IT DOESN'T CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF WHAT IS IN THERE.
AS YOU KNOW, LAURA, I'M ONE
OF THE FEW PEOPLE THAT HAVE
AND HAVING HAD THAT
CONSISTENT WITH THE MEMO
THAT THE PUBLIC WAS ABLE TO
SEE TODAY THAT WAS DRAFTED
BY THE MAJORITY MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR EVERYBODY
THE QUESTION POSED TO DEVIN
NUNES TONIGHT BY BRET BAIER
ABOUT THAT ISSUE OF THE
UNDERLYING APPLICATION.
LET'S WATCH.
>> DID YOU READ THE ACTUAL
FISA APPLICATIONS?
>> NO, I DIDN'T.
THE AGREEMENT WE MADE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
WAS TO CREATE A READING ROOM
AND ALLOW ONE MEMBER AND TWO
INVESTIGATORS TO GO OVER AND
OUR COMMITTEE WOULD BE THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE OVERSIGHT
PROSECUTOR TO GO AND DO
THIS.
>> Laura: IN OTHER WORDS,
VICKI, HE WAS GOING OFF HALF
COCKED.
HE DIDN'T READ THE THING AND
IS HE PUSHING THIS MEMO.
I GUESS THAT'S WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> HE WAS FOLLOWING THE
RULES THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT MANDATED IN ORDER
TO GIVE THEM THE DOCUMENTS.
THOSE ARE ALWAYS NEGOTIATED.
>> Laura: WHAT BOTHERS YOU
MOST WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN
TODAY WITH THIS MEMO.
>> SO MANY THINGS.
THE FIRST THING IS THAT
MCCABE SAID THAT THEY WOULD
NOT HAVE SOUGHT, THEY WOULD
NOT HAVE EVEN GOING TO THE
FISA COURT UNLESS THEY HAD
THAT DOSSIER.
THAT JUST IS REALLY SCARY.
AND THEN THE BOOT STRAPPING,
OF COURSE, THE DOSSIER WAS
USED TO PUT IN THE STORY TO
PLANT A STORY WITH MICHAEL,
THE JOURNALISTIC CORE.
HE JUST TAKES WHATEVER THE
LEFT GIVES HIM AND HE
REWRITES IT.
THEY?
>> OF COURSE.
>> Laura: THIS WHOLE THING,
THEY ARE ALL HELPING.
IT'S A BOOSTING SOCIETY.
BOOSTING EVERYONE ELSE'S
NARRATIVE.
VERY AGGRESSIVE LACK OF
CURIOSITY ON THE PART OF THE
JOURNALIST TO SAY WHERE DID
YOU GET THIS INFORMATION?
LET ME LOOK AT THE
UNDERLYING.
BYRON, YOU WERE THE FIRST
PERSON TO GET THIS MEMO, IT
LOOKS LIKE IN THE MEDIA.
ONE OTHER PERSON DID AS
WELL.
WHAT VICKI JUST SAID ABOUT
THE ISSUE OF WHAT THEY KNEW,
WHEN THEY KNEW IT.
WHAT STANDS OUT FOR YOU,
ESPECIALLY THE MCCABE POINT,
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI?
>> WELL, THEY SAID THE MEMO
SAYS THAT THE DOSSIER WAS AN
ESSENTIAL PARTY OF THIS
APPLICATION AND AS VICKI
SAID GOES ON TO SAY THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT
ARE REALLY FOUR THINGS THAT
THEY CITE AS THE REASON FOR
THIS WARRANT IS THE DOSSIER,
IT'S THAT MICHAEL ISIKOFF
ARTICLE.
THE PAPADOPOULOS CASE.
>> Laura: YAHOO NEWS.
>> PAPADOPOULOS CASE AND
CARTER PAGE'S HISTORY.
BIGGEST OF ALL OF THOSE.
SO IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL AND IT REALLY
SUPPORTS THIS IDEA WITHOUT
THE DOSSIER, THERE IS NO
APPLICATION.
>> GEORGE PAPGD, I MEAN WHAT
THE HECK WAS HE DOING
BRAGGING IN A BAR THAT
HILLARY'S EMAILS WERE GOING
TO COME OUT SOON AND THE
IS THAT A REASON FOR HIM TO
ONE OF THE MOST LUDICROUS
THINGS I HAVE HEARD TO BASE
ANYTHING ON.
>> LAURA?
>> Laura: GO AHEAD.
PLAYED THERE, LAURA, ABOUT
DIFFERENT NUNES' DECISION.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU SEND OVER
TREY GOWDY?
THE BEST LAWYER IN CONGRESS,
A LAWYER WHO HAS VIEWED
HUNDREDS, IF NOT THOUSANDS
OF AGENT DECLARATION
AFFIDAVITS AND SUBMISSIONS
TO FEDERAL COURTS?
WHY WOULDN'T YOU SANDY GUY
WHO KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT HE IS
LOOKING FOR.
WHAT WOULD PAST THE SMELL
TEST AND WHAT WOULDN'T.
I THINK HE OUGHT TO BE
APPLAUDED FOR THAT DECISION.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, ARE
YOU GOING TO MOVE TO PUSH TO
COURSE?
BUT THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING
ACCURATE.
MCCABE DIDN'T SAY THAT IN
HIS CLOSED DOOR TESTIMONY.
THAT THEY WOULDN'T HAVE GONE
AFTER THE FISA WARRANT
WITHOUT THAT DOSSIER.
THEY ARE DISPUTING THAT
TONIGHT ON OTHER NETWORKS.
I KNOW BYRON WANTS TO SEE
IT.
>> YEAH.
I THINK TRANSCRIPTS OF
WITNESS INTERVIEWS.
THOSE CAN BE REDACTED AND
MADE PUBLIC.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS' MEMO,
THE MINORITY MEMO OUGHT TO
BE MADE PUBLIC, TOO.
I WILL TELL YOU, HAVING READ
THAT ADAM SCHIFF DRAFTED
THAT AND IT'S CHOCK-FULL OF
SOURCES AND METHODS.
IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO BE
HEAVILY REDACTED BEFORE IT'S
[LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: SO THAT DOES HAVE
SOURCES AND METHODS THAT
THEY COMPLAINED ABOUT
GETTING COMPROMISED.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
>> IT DOES.
I WILL SAY THIS ABOUT THE
UNDERLYING DOCUMENTS THAT I
HAVE BEEN ABLE ABLE TO
REVIEW.
YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD TO TAKE
FOUR PHONE BOOKS WORTH OF
INFORMATION AND DISTILL IT
DOWN TO FOUR PAGES.
SO I THINK IT'S FAIR WHEN
THE FBI DIRECTOR SAYS NOT
EVERY MATERIAL FACT IS
CRITICISM.
BUT AS SOMEONE THAT HAS
REVIEWED THE UNDERLYING
DOCUMENTS, THE STORY ENDS
OUT SAME WAY.
RAIN
>>IN
>> Laura: TAKE THINGS OUT OF
NEED THE WHOLE CONTEXT.
YOU ARE MISSING KEY FACTS
THAT WOULD INFORM WHY THIS
WARRANT WAS APPLIED FOR WHEN
IT WAS APPLIED FOR.
YOU REJECT THAT?
>> I REJECT THAT AS YOU
KNOW, LAURA, I'M A FORMER
TERRORISM PROSECUTOR.
I HAVE SIGNIFICANT
APPLICATIONS BEFORE.
AND I JUST, AS I LOOKED AT
THE UNDERLYING APPLICATIONS,
I KEPT COMING TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION.
I WOULDN'T MAKE THESE
FISA JUDGE.
>> Laura: YEAH.
SOMEONE WAS ASKING FOR A
WARRANT.
>> Laura: YEAH, I GET THAT
CONGRESSMAN.
WE GOT TO GET TO BYRON AND
SOMETHING IN THAT
APPLICATION THAT REFERENCED
A POLITICAL MOTIVATION FOR
THE DOSSIER IN THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE GOT SWALWELL WAS OVER
THERE TALKING ABOUT THAT
NOT MENTIONING HILLARY BY
NAME BUT THERE WAS A
POLITICAL MOTIVATION.
WAS THAT IN THERE.
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHY
ERIC SWALWELL WOULD KNOW
THAT BECAUSE HE HASN'T HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY.
>> Laura: WAS IT IN THERE?
DID THEY REFERENCE A
POLITICAL MOTIVATION FOR THE
DOSSIER IN THE APPLICATION?
>> WELL, I CAN'T DISCLOSE
ANYTHING SPECIFICALLY THAT'S
IN THE UNDERLYING DOCUMENT.
>> Laura: OKAY.
>> WHAT I CAN AGAIN
REITERATE IS IT DOESN'T
CHANGE MY OPINION AND
CONCLUSION.
>> Laura: OKAY.
THIS NUNES HINTED THAT THERE
IS MORE TO COME THAT THIS IS
LET'S WATCH.
>> ARE THERE OTHER MEMOS
THAT ARE GOING TO COME OUT?
ARE THERE OTHER MEMOS?
YOU SAID THIS WAS PHASE ONE.
>> YEAH.
SO THIS COMPLETES JUST THE
FISA ABUSE SPORGS OF OUR
INVESTIGATION.
INVESTIGATION WHICH INVOLVES
OTHER DEPARTMENTS,
SPECIFICALLY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Laura: BYRON, WHAT DO YOU
KNOW.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING THAT
WE HAVE HAD INDICATIONS
RECENTLY THAT THERE IS SOME
SORT OF INVOLVEMENT IN THE
BUT WE KNOW THAT JOHN KERRY,
THE SECRETARY OF STATE WAS
BRIEFED ON THE CONTENTS OF
THE DOSSIER.
HERE.
>> I WILL TELL YOU ANOTHER
PHASE THAT SHOULD HAPPEN.
THE FISA COURT BETTER GET
BUSY.
THEY ARE EITHER INCREDIBLY
GROSSLY NEGLIGENT.
AND DON'T YOU THINK THEY
>> Laura: COULD THE CARTER
PAGE, EVEN WITH SOVEREIGN
IMMUNITY, COULD CARTER PAGE
FILE IN COURT AN ACTION FOR
ABUSE OF PROCESS OR
SANCTIONS AGAINST JUSTICE
A FISA APPLICATION?
IS THERE ANY GROUNDS FOR
THAT?
>> HE COULD FILE SOMETHING
WITH THE D.C. BAR.
WHEREVER THESE PEOPLE ARE
MEMBERS OF THE BAR.
HE HAS FILED A CASE IN NEW
YORK.
>> Laura: UM-HUH.
>> HE DID IT PRO SE.
BUT HE HAS A CASE.
>> Laura: COMEY'S CHIEF OF
STAFF CHUCK ROSENBERG ALL
OVER TELEVISION TODAY LOOK,
IF THEY REALLY HAD CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS.
IF THE TRUMP PEOPLE OR THE
GONE TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AND VOICED THEIR
CONCERNS.
THEY COULD HAVE GONE TO THE
PRIVACY AND CIVIL LIBERTIES
OVERSIGHT BOARD AND THEY
COULD GO TO THE FBI.
OVER MSNBC.
OF THIS BECAUSE THERE WILL
BE AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
INVESTIGATION OF THE
HANDLING OF THIS AND IT'S
GOING TO COME OUT IN 2020 OR
21.
>> Laura: IT WILL BE TOO
LATE.
THE DAMAGE WILL HAVE BEEN